right here so this Carlos I'm 10 games
and making Weyland Metroidvania
action-adventure RPG in a pixel art
style this game you go to towns talk to
people take West go to dungeons and all
that RPG stuff is a sidescroller review
original here
[Music]
it does
presently managers
he goes from zero to hero very very
retro very classic
this market
abilities so right now
or become a control
tell me more about his ability so right
now first up a face
but action right now I can see
we lost
you'll have to punch you have to travel
and explore too
forcing them on the ground inside so you
know the action begins
so we got our knife attack role that you
had
this is very classy is actually game
back you up
really cool style so dope now as far as
like the weapon doesn't get other things
[Music]
is trapped you
[Music]
next
new enemies
[Music]
like hitting all the arrows here and I
just get low
you get the quest
Oh
I also got this shield so I can have a
quick shield
okay so we have sword and shield
Botanica
so calling around I see this
niall shorter you can see it
I
yeah I like to I like there we go
[Music]
most difficult areas
we don't care all the Ravens person
so there's a lot of the elements learned
a lot of a fasiq jumping you
very challenging very precise you don't
have
from you often yes
[Music]
they're here
don't really get the will of the people
a quest for RPG in a side-scroller
database it that's why I'm feeling
failing on that
so here you free this work
right indicated by the sound but you'll
be able to follow him go to the
locations in the world
location the world map was about the
spoiler there
black holes are we looking to release
mentally
okay next our campaign crunching every
17
[Music]
we'll have a stretch goal for America so
we will start working on the 40
at the same time
after
okay we'll turn the vehicle
the three mayor come
did you say Nintendo's my BAE because I
think this this title would be perfect
for Nintendo's
now does he ever get any projectiles yes
yes it's very subtle
it don't take place value as a symbol in
a while
[Music]
I have to admit you won't be over
Finland thank you a little simpler but
this is very much available with
hardcore RPG mechanics tell us about
that takes a lot of people want to
contribute but it's game put that
information out let the fans know for
kick-started package who have access to
the demo right away and after that
you'll be able to experience this story
from the beginning so the other first
levels and from that you just get
updates on the other games releasing and
next year 10 a 19 like I think we're in
this year like next Christmas when I
bought this thing become a payment game
was great
our style looks great awesome
so this beautiful lady then she's a
little busy but we win a pen card to
co-sign this game you're cocky little
podcaster Oh Mitchell and very cool